[Music]
[Music]
so
brenda and i had a common vision of
raising our children in a house like
this
when we were design students
[Music]
we intentionally looked for a house with
a basement so that we could turn it into
a quiet
private workspace that was separated
from family life upstairs
[Music]
moving here was a deliberate attempt to
escape from the city area which i grew
up in
and be with nature in hope that the
hermetic environment
would allow for more reflection when i
first started age 55 more than 20 years
ago
i asked myself what is a workspace
why do people work in offices can we
redefine a workspace
and can they be mobile and would the
workspace
influence the type of work produced
it soon became obvious that ultimately
my mind is the design studio
the design studio is there for anywhere
and everywhere
it is an inner world that travels with
me wherever i go
in search of ideas
[Music]
the act of walking seeing and thinking
makes me feel alive
spotting the unfamiliar within the
familiar intrigues me
i'm fascinated by nature because nature
is the empty thesis of design which is
nurtured and man-made
yet nature has its own universal design
which can inform the way we create
the lower piers trail allows me to be
conveniently immersed in nature and
observe its wonders
[Music]
the trio's thoughtfully designed
boardwalk integrates harmoniously with
the surrounding greens and allows for a
safe and pleasant stroll
the signages along the boardwalk provide
clear information
and are unintrusive
we don't have to visit a museum to
appreciate good design
because design is everywhere often it is
at the older strata titled shopping
centers where design
gems and unexpected oddities can be
found
these independently owned shops are
refreshingly authentic as compared to
the glossy stores which mostly occupy
our retail landscape
one of these shops is memory lane at the
adelphi
which carries a wide range of selected
records
like a mini graphic design museum some
of the most famous works can be found
here
from iconic album covers designed by
peter saville and mark farrow
to the surreal imagery created by
hypnosis for pink floyd and black
sabbath
i admire artists who have the indie or
independent spirit
those who dare experiment and stay true
to their artistic expression
while bravely ignoring what is radio
friendly and acceptable by society
these bans have shown me that sticking
to one's belief and passion can lead to
unexpected possibilities
skateboard culture is one of the
influences behind streetwear which in
turn has a big influence on fashion
today
speed fire at peninsular shopping center
is a treasure trove of
original skateboard graphics and
illustrations
brands like santa cruz oil peralta and
independent trucks have been around for
decades and continue to provide a whole
array of sought after merchandise
what makes the graphics cool is that
they are not just merely a part of the
spot
but the association with a subculture of
free spirited risk takers
who embrace failure as part of their
creative pursuit
[Music]
the extreme skatepark is a fascinating
urban landscape and piece of
architecture
parts of it reminiscent of brutally
sculptures
consisting of a vertical and combo bowl
as well as a mix
of street obstacles this control
environment is a far cry from the days
when skateboarding stunts were practiced
illegally
in public spaces often causing vandalism
and public disruption
but perhaps this is one of the things
that makes skateboard subculture
inspiring
skateboard culture is about being
disruptive and breaking the rules of
established norms and by doing so new
movements and audiences
emerge
subcultures have played a big role in
shaping the way many of us see
things through its lens we definitely
can learn to be more open
and inclusive towards alternative forms
of expression
opinions thinking and ways of living
my name is hansen ho i'm a graphic
designer at age 55
do i continue reading
you